[Music]
[Applause]
sound sounds familiar yeah
now these calendars just didn't sell
here's this first one it's called is Ben
Affleck talking or just breathing I
don't have to try him oh boy you're hot
I don't I think he's just breathing you
can't yeah but it's they're all hard I
think he's talking I don't know yeah I'm
gonna say breathing there and that's
probably talking slash breathe yeah yeah
and then I don't know what he's you know
Ansel Adams was the great photographer
known for his beautiful black-and-white
photographs of landscape yeah big huge
nature yeah and yeah beautiful and
gorgeous this I can see why this didn't
sell what's called Ansel Adams the
agoraphobe years it's he just went
wouldn't get out of the house but still
tried to do his job not many knew yeah
look at this one here this is I I think
he was near the Grand Canyon the Grand
Canyon yeah I just wouldn't go outside
but you get the idea yeah yeah we're
really
the idea has shame really
here's one I can't believe nobody wanted
this it's called Tommy Lee Jones wants
you to have a great effing year now I
can get through the year with him
looking at me yeah wow that's a rough
one
yeah well the December one was sort of
festive yeah look at this one someone
hearing your story about Christmas in
Albany so it starts out with him just
starting to hear the story and then it
takes you through the year as the story
keeps going and yeah he's just really
and then it just doesn't
[Music]
I'm gonna keep this one and use it
because I love it the Larry King zodiac
look at this one to hold yeah it takes
it all through the air there's Aries
right Wow
I love Pisces I've caught fish like
Larry can I look I don't know we're
gonna get emails about this one but I
just have to show it all right called
the I hate cats calendar you got the one
about to get hit by lava deserves it
I'm sorry yeah yeah it's whole attitude
is I'm not gonna I have time I like this
one there's one of those word of the day
word of the day calendar yeah yeah it's
the Sarah Palin's word of the day
calendar these are just words that I
guess she came up with Wow they got flag
up and yeah look at this one right here
guns I'm just too juiced you know that's
a fun one and then look at this one
right here Pakistan Afghanistan these
are all great words I'm enjoying this
more than the crowd will bomb Obama
nation and then what the real calendar
was was a New Yorker calendar
do you think we would make this
ourselves
that's how television works everybody we
use an existing New Yorker cartoon
calendar yeah and then pasted our jokes
to the front we saved a lot of money
that way and excite exciting peek behind
the curtain for ya that's a chance for
you to see how television really look at
this one and finally uber drivers
creeply looking at you know stars proper
god oh our go look at the head
[Applause]
money wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]